Hey everybody! My name is Daria and I'm going to telling you 10 interesting psychology facts about human feelings.
So, listen on if you want to know
Number 1: There's actually a phobia for losing one's phone.
"Nomophobia" is a term describing the fear of being without a mobile device
or beyond mobile phone contact.
According to a study, 54% of those who were asked
actually said that they've experienced 'Nomophobia' before.
And overall, women were more likely to suffer from 'Nomophobia' than men.
Number 2: Without realising it, we're actually affected by other people's moods.
Researchers call this phenomonon 'Emotional Conjugation
This is a natural process that pre-wired our brain, through mirror neurons, that allow us
to sense and reflect on other's emotions.
And as stated in the 'Chamelion Effect', we have the natural tendency to imitate another person's
speech inflections and physical expressions.
We usually mimic the actions of those we surround ourselves with.
Number 3: In the past few years, psychology researchers have found a good literal truth
embedded in the metaphorical phrase comparing love to pain
Mirror imaging studies have shown that brain regions involved in processing physical pain
overlap considerably with those tied to social anguish.
'Broken Heart Syndrome' is categorised by normal coronary arteries,
regional wall motion abnormalities that extend beyond a single vascular bend,
and often a precipitating stresser.
It's temporary that this is often brought up on social situations such as the loss of a loved one.
Number 4: When we hug, the chemical that the brain releases is a hormone called 'Oxytocin';
a hormone recognised for it's role in social attachment and
facilitations of social interaction. It's also important in the formation of trust.
Number 5: It was proposed in one study, that the normal, unremarkable experiences associated with
everyday living could deplete one's capacity to resist moral temptations.
The study proposes that most likely, people have less self-control when they're tired.
Another study concluded that the average adult has less self-control as the day wears on,
becoming more likely to become "immoral" by the end of the afternoon.
Number 6: Desensitisation is defined as the diminished emotional responsiveness to a negative or aversive stimulus
after repeated exposure to it.  In a study conducted recently, parents who were subjected to watching movies
that contained violence and sex have shown that there is an increase in acceptance to both types of content.
Even to the extent of willingness to showing it to their children.
There is also evidence among people who play video games.
Number 7: I don't think it's a new thing that we consider chocolate as the new 'love drug'.
Chocolate has been widely known as being a staple for showing love.
But why is that so? It contains
'Tryptophan', a chemical in the brain that is used to produce 'Serotonin' the 'feel good' brain chemical
that plays a major role in positive mood, emotional health, proper sleep and balanced appetite.
It works by stimulating the brains pleasure centers and reaches it's peak level during orgasm.
Number 8: Psychological researchers classified 6 facial expressions which correspond to
distinct universal emotions.
Disgust, Sadness, Happiness, Fear, Anger and Surprise.
Theorists have also hypothesized that the universals are to be found in the relationship
between distinctive moments of the facial muscles and the particular emotions.
Number 9: Mirror neurons are the brains hardware floor,
harmonising individuals to their environment.
The mirror neurons when you blush when you see someone else humiliated, flinch when someone
someone else is struck, can't resist the urge to laugh in a big group of people
when seeing the group stuck with giggles.
It's been said that these neurons have given us the capability of empathy,
allowing us to feel what other people feel, both physically and emotionally. :)